starting monday dale mckay won't know
the vaccination status of his customers
coming into his restaurants in saskatoon
and regina and he's fine with that it is
a bit of a a bit of a chore for
restaurants and for businesses to be
checking passports every time we have a
new guest come in since october patrons
were required to show proof that they
were fully vaccinated or of a negative
covert 19 test we chose not to
necessarily go with the negative tests
just because it just added another level
of kind of confusion when was the test
taken all that kind of stuff but on
monday the province is dropping those
requirements premier scott moe said
businesses who wish to keep enforcing it
must do so on their own if a
municipality or a private business
wanted to move forward
with that policy
i suppose they should do so my advice
would be to consult a lawyer mckay is
accepting the change and that some
customers might have coveted like they
might have the flu
he says his staff will keep wearing
masks even after all other health orders
are dropped at the end of the month so
customers feel safe he just wants things
to go back to normal
but the virus that causes covet 19 is
still spreading this snapshot of the
health authority's internal covet 19
dashboard obtained by global news shows
nearly 400 people needing care
according to a recent doctor's update
the non-icu system is at capacity
and in the push to get to the living
with covid stage of the pandemic the
government stop sharing daily updates
an infectious disease physician says
people need more information and now is
not the time to drop public safety
measures the challenge here again is
uh trying to sort of understand sort of
what the rationale for all of this was
you know and sort of what the rush was
wong is worried fewer people will get
their shots without the health order in
place
you need vaccines to live with covid
nathaniel dove global news saskatoon